so but with that my dad's peeing behind
a tree in public in central park sheep's
metal whatever yeah with that
1984 strawberry fields everything just
pissing on it
dan aykroyd comes rollerblading by down
i forgot this was about there
yeah i forgot and i i just this was like
a uh
this was like a uh m night shyamalan
type twist for me yeah
yeah dan aykroyd that's what made me
think of it dan aykroyd comes
rollerblading by
stops starts flirting with my mother
my father sees that sees there was a
branch
by a tree chases dan aykroyd with the
dream branch
and aykroyd rollerblades
rollerblade spy rollerblades by
and then with all that it's dan aykroyd
and dan aykroyd it's it's dan eckhardt
but my dad
that's not his height at a time but from
what my mother said
my dad yelled at dan aykroyd
[ __ ] you bill murray stay away from my
wife
oh that stinks he did stick so he called
him did he know
or did he not know my dad knew that
because dan acquired bill murray were
very famous no but did your dad think he
was bill murray which is what i think
but if your dad had the wherewithal to
call the wrong name because he think it
would bite him
in the ass like like insult him or not
no my dad just thought it was bill
murray but
i think my dad does boomer because
that's not the first time my father has
done that
did i ever tell you but yeah there was a
time where my dad we were sitting at
joe's pizza in the west village we're
sitting there i was about 19.
favorite size fantastic joe's pizza
forever new york hit the west village go
to joe's pizza
um we're sitting there having a slice
and um and uh i forgot what we were
doing in the city maybe we were on our
way to a next game or something like
that my dad would always take me
that was my dad's uh incentive for doing
good in school or
cleaning my room whatever it's like we
take go to the next game
yeah you want yeah
so we're there and you know joe's gets a
lot of celebrities that come in there
and steven tyler comes in from aerosmith
oh wow
right he comes in and my dad's like oh
this freaking guy
steven tyler and he sits
starts sitting down stephen tyler just
standing there starts cutting his pizza
with a knife and a fork and my dad goes
i can't believe this freaking guy
with a knife and a fork eating the pizza
in new york city like that he goes i got
to tell him something
he goes hey bon jovi that's not how we
do this
and then people were like what is bon
jovi because nobody even knows stephen
tyler i was the only one that noticed
that
so so well not i was the only one that
was saying but he's you know conspicuous
or whatever
and my dad's like yeah i [ __ ] and
then my dad just keeps saying he's like
yeah bon jovi
i i kept saying that there's stephen
aerosmith but my you know my dad like
when he dropped me off that night my mom
was like we met bon jovi i'm like it's
not
bon jovi it's not jon bon jovi it's a
different guy
you